bonjour yam collet vient d'acheter cette
maison est en bon propriétaire il se
présente ses occupants mais il ne s'agit
pas d'une simple visite de courtoisie
l'homme dirige une entreprise qui se
spécialise dans leurs achats de
propriétés squatter une fois
propriétaire des lieux ils se chargent
d'expulser les squatteurs avant de
rénover pour revendre c'est une surprise
pour kamel l'un des occupants qui
affirment payer un loyer
nous sommes ici moi g t d'or et les
chefs d'une maison pour allouer je dis
oui roger perron et je rentre ici
kamel est un migrant en situation
irrégulière en france il dit payer 300
euros par mois pour une chambre dans
cette maison qu'il partage avec deux
autres jeunes hommes
il n'y a pas d'eau chaude et l'eau fuit
de partout
ici ce sont des squatters qui se sont
fait berner par un pseudo chef qui leur
fait payer loyer tous les mois
et c'est pas un cas isolé on a souvent
des personnes qui vont squatter des
biens et qui vont louer à des squatters
à des migrants les biens qu'ils ont
ouverte a bien compris il faut plus
payer le loyer des situations pareilles
and collet en encontre souvent au fil de
la quarantaine de dossiers qu'il traite
tous les mois partout enfin si quand les
squatteurs comme vous vous partez de
vous même
moi je donne 1000 euros par squatteurs
donc on vous donne mille euros chacun là
vous êtes 3 ça fait 3000 euros ça nous
parce que 3000 euros d'où si vous pensez
pas on va les donner à l'avocat et
l'avocat doit vous mettre dehors
un argument souvent convaincant un
entrepreneur la prochaine ça nous évite
des procédures qui peuvent durer
18 24 30 voire beaucoup plus on a
dossier actuellement où on est à plus de
30 ans de squats et nous avons aussi un
autre dossier actuellement sud de la
france où il ya eu 14 ans de procédure
le squatteur est toujours dans
l'appartement et les héritiers en sont à
48 mille euros de frais d'avocat si on
connaît mal l'ampleur du phénomène des
squats en france on sait en revanche
qu'il est très difficile pour les
propriétaires de faire valoir leurs
droits la loi vient d'ailleurs d'être
modifié pour que les propriétaires
puissent obtenir l'aide du préfet de
police dans les 48 heures sans devoir
passer par les tribunaux si leur
résidence principale est occupée par des
squatters
mais en cas de résidence secondaire ou
d'une propriété dont on mérite par
exemple ça reste un chemin de croix en
france il faut imaginer qu'une procédure
judiciaire pour un squatteur c'est la
même que celle qu on utilise pour
expulser un locataire qui paieraient pas
son loyer
donc c'est en général ça dépend des
tribunaux mais c'est à peu près 18 mois
parfois 24 mois pour obtenir une vision
de justice qui ordonne l'expulsion
pour l'instant le squatteur il est chez
vous et à la france n'est pas encore
terminée pour le propriétaire c'est un
parcours du combattant vous comprenez
puisque il doit obtenir le concours de
la force publique du préfet et le préfet
peut refuser d'accorder le concours la
force publique parce qu'ils considèrent
que le squatteur à des enfants en bas
âge il ya il fait trop froid
donc il ya tout un tas d'os motifs qui
peuvent que conduire le préfère refuser
d'accorder concours de la force publique
raul antunès en sait quelque chose il a
acheté cette bâtisse pour y déménager
son entreprise de climatisation et ses
40 employés avant qu'ils ne puissent
faire les travaux d'aménagement monsieur
antunès a été alertée par la mairie une
famille de squatters avaient élu
domicile dans ses locaux
l'entrepreneur a pu rapidement obtenir
une ordonnance d'expulsion du tribunal
puis plus rien
- quoi les gens je n'en veux pas alors
que c'est le système qui laisse faire
ces choses-là après qu'ils nous laissent
dedans c'est hallucinant c'est
hallucinant que là je pensais qu'une
fois qu'il avait évacué tout le monde
que le lendemain ou dans les semaines
qui suivent il a eu bien il ya des
entreprises prévues pour nettoyage vous
nettoie le bâtiment après les travaux
pourra toujours parler mais moins
l'essentiel est là quand même
mais non finalement non quand les
squatteurs en finalement été expulsé au
bout de neuf mois il était passé d'une
dizaine
plusieurs centaines de personnes les
locaux ont aujourd'hui des airs de
dépotoir ou lente une s évaluent les
dommages causés à sa propriété à près de
300 mille dollars
ils intentent un recours contre la
préfecture qui a tardé à agir
le vrai problème c'est la crise du
logement en france et des gens qui n'ont
pas d'autre solution en particulier à
paris en région ile-de-france donc ils
viennent s'installer chez vous parce
qu'ils n'ont pas d'autres solutions et
l'état évidemment préfère que ce soit le
propriétaire qui payent l'addition
plutôt que
ce soit les deniers publics qui
financent tout ça donc le problème
fondamental évidemment ces problèmes du
logement
les squatteurs ne sont en fait que la
pointe émergée d'une crise beaucoup plus
profonde celle des sans logis et des mal
logés
ils sont 4 millions en france ici marie
ève bédard radio-canada paris